John why are you making such a strong
move to produce write and direct at this
stage of your career you've done many
things and seems like mmm now you're
taking the surface well first of all she
produces idle produce okay yeah I don't
know from I don't know from producing at
all because if two of us are the same
one of us is unnecessary I thought I was
going to be doing this right after Dukes
I wrote and directed the last episode of
Dukes and thought that naturally what
I'd be doing from that point on was
telling stories and I had written a
couple of screenplays and they really
weren't very good so I'm glad that it
didn't happen wasn't ready for it but
I've always been trying before Dukes
when I was eight millimeter film 50 feet
at a time with no sound that you'd have
to have developed at Cal door in Mount
Kisco New York that's what i was doing
cutting pieces of film together with
tape on a shag carpet so I being a
filmmaker or a storyteller has always
been what what I felt if he said what
John what do you do I said well I tell
stories well you singing country music
yeah but I'm telling stories well you're
doing this and doing that well yeah but
I'm telling stories the difference is
now there there are my stories there
there my experiences that have come out
and and like rust on a bumper they have
got to come out they've got to see the
light of day you can't just keep
painting them over or one of these days
the bumper is going to fall off so have
to have to tell them but it's through
this relationship that I realize I
actually could there's a lot to it
there's a whole lot to it's why I'm
quick to say I'm not a producer
producers are the ones that actually
make they set the stage so that the
magic can happen and in there by doing
create their own kind of magic but
without them
their stories you just tell over and
over they change every time you tell
them because you get bored and then they
kind of go away and I'm glad they're not
going away anymore right was i messing
with my glasses like me where I took him
away from it sorry
you